so Batman's getting a new actors stuffed
into the cape and cowl that Affleck will
play an older more seasoned Dark Knight
in the upcoming film Superman vs Batman
now it's the vs. that bothers me see
Frank Miller's one came closest to
figuring out how this wouldn't be the
world's finest one-sided fight in his
graphic novel The Dark Knight Returns
but the letter has a slice it it's an
adorable flying alien versus the
sadistic trustafarian with a tricked-out
tool belt but all of you shrill internet
nerds were already certain that batfleck
is going to bat fail are getting way
ahead of yourselves nobody thought that
slapstick funny guy Michael Keaton would
be any good in Tim Burton's original but
keen to combine the dramatic intensity
of beetle use with the campy suavity of
Johnny dangerous I'm Batman think about
it Christian Bale nailed Batman by
mentioning the wounded but resourceful
child from a part of the Sun with the
well-heeled serial killer from American
Psycho
now the fully val kilmer
it makes us man to doc holliday instead
of his along Jim Morrison I don't know
Matt Martin the kid from real genius
George Clooney he was like a mash-up of
his overshadowed lead and from dusk till
dawn and whatever the hell he was doing
on the facts of life dr. Doug Ross where
are you
which brings us back to Affleck what
could work for him well an admixture of
the ambivalent bank robber from the town
and his volatile yuppie from changing
lands that I could get me on what if we
get the slightly stoned
daredevil plus it's a sociopathic
backdoor man from mall rats that that
would be bad like better into the solar
plexus bad actually this Batman is like
a stayer double plus anything
we are both Armageddon Affleck plus
paycheck Affleck also a recipe for
disaster
Pearl Harbor plus reindeer games thanks
for watching one thing sure Matt Damon
would make it great Robin if he plays in
this half Good Will Hunting and half
Jason Bourne what about you let me know
who you'd cast as the Boy Wonder in the
comments